okay hi everyone
welcome to another episode of science
and technology q a
for kids and others so we seem to have
all kinds of questions here that are
left over from previous times
there's one from deceive here that asks
is it is it possible for there to be a
different world
or civilization deep in the oceans that
we do not know about
well depends what you mean by a uh
a world or civilization if um
uh let's let's take that in several
different directions
so one possibility is could there be you
know
deep sea fish that have somehow managed
to
achieve some high level of civilization
and have built fish cities
and uh are doing elaborate things under
the oceans
i don't think we could rule that out i
think um
we have at this point so what's known
about deep oceans
um there is uh what's usually called
bathymetry data
depth of the ocean data for the whole
earth
and that's been found by um
i think mostly uh the the way
so how do you find out how deep the
oceans are people always used to
just have uh a weight at the end of a
string
basically and just let that out from a
ship
at a particular place and just see how
far you had to let it out before it hit
the bottom of the ocean
that in more recent times
being able to use sonar that is having
pulses of sound
that you put in the water and you listen
for the echo of the
sound coming back from the from the
bottom of the ocean that's the more
recent way to do
uh to find out depths of the ocean i
mean one of the one of the surprising
things about the oceans
is that sound travels very well
underwater particularly
in the deep ocean where the water is
very still and uh
one of the sort of surprising things is
that uh sound can travel all the way
across a big ocean
when it goes into the deep ocean what
tends to happen is that the way
the pressure changes in the ocean the uh
it's it's like the refractive index the
speed that sound goes at is such
the sound will get kind of pulled into
the deep ocean and then it goes through
this kind of channel
in the deep ocean where it can go uh
without
really being attenuated at all without
without getting uh
less loud at all and it can go thousands
of miles
um and uh then be detectable and that's
you know that's a
that's a trick that the whales use and
that's why you know whale songs
can presumably be heard by whales
uh all the way across the ocean it's
kind of the the we're not
we we think of ourselves very proudly as
being a civilization that has managed to
have instantaneous communication around
the world using
fiber optics and radio communications
and so on but actually
the the whales sort of already have it
with sound in the ocean which can
propagate a long way
now in terms of of what might
exist in the oceans that we don't know
about uh
it's been not that long for example
hydrothermal vents
places where there is kind of uh
hot stuff that comes from the that's
associated with the
the hot interior of the earth kind of
bubbling up through the the ocean floor
people have thought for example there's
nothing alive in hydrothermal vents
but because they're full of sulfur and
other kinds of
chemicals that don't seem to agree with
most kinds of life
but then i'm not sure how long ago a few
decades ago
life was discovered in hydrothermal
vents and in fact interesting and
unusual
kinds of life that worked in ways that
were different from the ones that we
were used to
were discovered there so it's you might
say well there's nothing there
but that that might not be true now
if we ask the question sort of what
level of civilization so to
speak might be achieved by the deep
ocean
things that are crawling around on the
ocean floor or the fish or the
or the mammals aquatic mammals or
whatever
this question of sort of what level of
civilization is achieved
that's always a somewhat difficult thing
to define because
you know we're used to our particular
civilization our way of communicating
using language our way of building
structures and so on
is that the only way for a civilization
to be and still be sort of a
sophisticated civilization i don't think
we can really answer that
it could be the case that uh you know
the
the if we if we define things to be sort
of human-like it could be the case that
you know the dolphins have been telling
epic stories to each other just like
the ancient greeks did with uh or or
many other kinds of civilizations have
done
um have been telling stories to each
other and kind of each one is
remembering them and then they're
passing them on by making
uh sort of dolphin sounds and so on to
other dolphins and there's a whole
there's a whole story of what's happened
there you know do we see
dolphin houses having been built well no
we don't but
i'm not sure that we would necessarily
say that the lack of
sort of shelters and things are
permanent objects that have been built
is necessarily characteristic of
civilization i think
the the presence of artifacts things
that were created in a certain way
uh to be used i again i'm not sure
how characteristic of civilization that
is i mean people have tried to sort of
get a rating of civilizations like like
uh
they say well how tall are the
structures that have been built by a
particular particular time in history
or how many levels of administrative
kind of structure how many levels of
from the boss to the to the uh sub boss
to the sub
sub boss and so on how many levels exist
in kind of government organization
things like this as kind of a a way of
getting a sense of the
level of civilization in different
different times in history in different
places so i'm not sure how we can
translate that to the
the fish civilization so to speak now i
mean it's also the case
that uh people wonder
in the past people have kind of uh
there's there's the the whole tale of
the lost city of atlantis
um which uh uh was sort of a very ocean
associated city
um that uh is written about in some
writings from antiquity and the sort of
a question was it real or was it not
the sort of famous example of this was
troy and the whole story of the
the iliad and the trojan war and things
like this which had been written about
and for a while for many centuries
people thought oh troy was just this
mythical thing that had been written
about didn't really exist
eventually it became clear in the mid to
late 1800s
there was a sort of big excavation
effort to find
troy and indeed it turns out it did
exist
as a real city somewhat confusingly
like many cities and sort of
archaeological
finds it had been built and
destroyed many times so there were like
uh you know
15 layers or something of different
versions of troy
that had been existed and then things
had fallen into disrepair
and then people just built on top of
that and so when it was excavated
unfortunately some mistakes were made
because people didn't know
that like the homer's troy the one that
was in the iliad
was you know layer five or something and
it was like let's go down to the lower
layers because
maybe they'll be more interesting and
let's use dynamite to kind of blow up
the the rocks and so on in the higher
layers and of course that destroyed a
bunch of archaeological
material which which leads one to these
questions about you know
if you know that there's some amazing
archaeological find
do you excavate it today or do you wait
for decades or maybe longer to say
oh we'll have better technology in the
future and we'll be able to better
preserve whatever existed in this
particular place
but atlantis is one of these things
which is sort of it's
it's being it's talked about as
something that exists
the lost city of atlantis or whatever um
that uh uh might have been covered by
the ocean or whatever
and nobody knows if it was real or or
not or whether it was just uh
a story and a way of describing sort of
this
alternate um i think it had various kind
of political systems that were
attributed to it
just to sort of an alternate um kind of
thing used as a
as a fictional device i mean it's it's
uh
there were plenty of these kinds of
things that i'm not quite sure when it
originated but the
the uh what it was at the city of el
dorado which was supposed to be the city
of gold
somewhere up the orinoco river in south
america
that turned out well it wasn't real in
fact even though
people spent lots of effort and had lots
of expeditions and spent lots of money
and even countries
like scotland famously i think almost
bankrupted itself
um through the effort to to find this
um this sort of mythical city didn't
work out
anyway just to to riff a little bit more
on this particular question
one of the things i remember when i was
a kid one of the
here's a thing that will happen in the
future is oh people will be living under
the oceans
and there were all kinds of designs and
pictures of you know
what a uh uh what a kind of an apartment
building
under the ocean would look like well
needless to say that hasn't come to pass
and it's sort of interesting to see what
kinds of things like that have happened
and what have not
i mean it turns out people uh
despite uh you know people people have
fairly
limited kinds of places that they end up
wanting to live i mean
people have uh uh you know cities then
there were suburbs that were enabled by
cars particularly and i suppose right
now
cities have seemed a little bit less
attractive after the last year
than they had previously and there's
sort of a push to go sort of more out
into suburbs
one imagines that one day if personal
aircraft you know of some kind come into
existence
that the suburbs might spread out
further because it will become easier
to go you know 50 miles out rather than
10 miles out or something
and people have often talked about kind
of the the exurbs and so on and the
question is
uh another thing that comes up is well
if people
are going into work in the city well
then they're going to want to live near
the city
but um maybe increasingly just like
well you know i've been a remote ceo for
30 years now
um and uh you know the world has kind of
uh
sort of caught up with that in a sense
or at least some parts of it have
and it's sort of become clear that more
things that you might have thought could
be done remotely
can actually be done remotely and some
things you thought might be able to be
done remotely
it's been kind of not very successful to
try and do them remotely
particularly things that involve a lot
of kind of human interaction like uh
education and things like this turns out
doesn't seem to work
although there are plenty of cases where
it has been made to work remotely
it's um uh in many situations it's it's
not as successful as people had hoped
even even with technology and and so on
but
um so it's an interesting question why
did the
cities under the ocean never take off so
to speak
i think it's like what's the point you
know it's a lot of effort
to uh have something where you are
uh sort of you know where you're living
under the ocean unless you've run out of
space on the land which we're pretty far
from doing
um why would you why would you do that
uh i mean sort of the
the other thing people talk about and
for slightly different reasons
is uh the whole idea of sea studying of
can you
just make your own country and just uh
have this you know perhaps it's even an
artificial island somewhere out in the
ocean because the way things are set
up the you know there are countries and
within a particular country defined by
its geographic borders
that the government of that country is
sort of supposedly in control and there
are
laws that apply and so on but then as
you get outside
some distance away from the borders of
that country into the ocean
then outside the territorial waters of
that country wherever they are 50 miles
whatever
the distance is away from the the
coastline of the country
kind of the way the world is set up it's
like okay
there is it's international waters there
is no country that that sort of owns
this
this um this region of the earth and
there's this kind of uh elaborately
constructed treaty the law of the sea
which was i think
uh an example of a place where some of
these ideas from things like game theory
and so on
were successfully used in this very very
multi-party negotiation of how should
one make
kind of this treaty about how uh what
should be true
about uh ships for example that are just
um um out in the sort of open ocean away
from cities
but so one thing one might say is well
gosh you know i want to start my own
country
let me have a um maybe it's a a floating
platform maybe it's something that's
tethered to the seabed or something
somewhere out in the in international
waters i've just got this thing that's
kind of my
like my micro country um and uh
so people occasionally have tried this
there was a place called sea world which
was an abandoned
uh oil platform in the north sea where
people just um was it called c
no it wasn't c oh gosh i'm i'm
forgetting its name it wasn't sea world
that's
that's the name of the place in uh in
san diego that has some
uh has lots of aquatic mammals and
things um the uh
uh oh gosh see something or other anyway
it was a
it was some kind of a um uh
it was sort of done um i think somewhat
tongue-in-cheek
with its own flag and its own this that
and the other
um and uh of course the problem is you
just put a thing in the middle of the
ocean
it's like nobody is necessarily going to
stick up for you
if somebody says well we don't want that
thing to be in the middle of the ocean
some
somebody can show up with a bunch of
navy ships and say you know we don't
like your
your sea land that was the name of the
thing i think sea land yeah
that was the um uh uh we don't like your
thing
and uh you know uh uh you know we're
going to blow it up so to speak
and if you're just this this little
uh piece of concrete in the middle of
the ocean um
it's it's it's hard to sort of mount a
defense to that so
it's always a bit of a problem and
people talk about this from time to time
and say oh we're not you know we're not
satisfied with how
governments are running things we just
want to make our own
um and uh have something where
we can uh sort of define our own country
by
making use of of land that doesn't
doesn't yet exist so to speak
and obviously there's a there's the
effort to make artificial islands that's
a whole separate and politically
complicated thing in many parts of the
world
well anyway that was a long answer to
that um that
question let me see um
well there's a question here from sm i
can't read the
the name uh what do you think about
civilization going to mars
um you know i think
that it sounds really cool when i was a
kid
everybody thought by the 1990s
there would be mars colonies and
and uh everybody would be excitedly
living on mars um one of the questions
and the challenges
about space in general is what do you
achieve with it
what what is the point what's it going
to be good for and
it wasn't obvious when the first
artificial satellites
in 1957 when you know sputnik was
first launched and circling around the
earth you know
one might have thought it was really
other than a kind of a
look this is a cool thing we can do um
its original sort of stated purpose was
things like
mapping the gravity of the earth by
seeing how the orbit varied as the thing
went around the earth and so on
clearly there are more things that
satellites turned out to be useful for
like
the idea of well like for example taking
satellite photographs of the earth
um being able to uh look at large
weather patterns on the earth
being able to use communication
satellites where you're broadcasting
radio signals to the earth and so on um
these are things which were not
completely
they were they were in some respects
predicted but they were not
it wasn't completely obvious that that
would be a big win
and it's still not clear whether in the
long term you know are we going to end
up with
a lot of satellite-based communications
or is it going to be high altitude
drones or is it going to be fiber
optics in the ground what's it going to
be there's sort of a complicated set of
competitions between those different
modalities and so it's not clear what
the value of sort of
just being in space is going to be and
and people
wondered is microgravity is the fact
that one is weightless in space because
one's like in orbit when sort of falling
just like
one would they when sort of always in
free fall so to speak when one's in
orbit or at least approximately so
and so everything is weightless there's
no effect of gravity
you know people have thought at
different times oh that might be super
useful for
for doing this or that kind of thing um
but
uh but so far that hasn't really panned
out
other than that um uh you know people
said oh that'll be the place where the
perfect silicon crystals
for the next generation of chips and so
on um
the uh um uh
and all that so i think um
uh the question of okay so let's say we
put a colony on the moon
what can we do with that or a colony on
mars which is a lot more difficult
sort of what's the what's the point well
one point might be
oh well you know let's extend our
civilization to mars because
gosh it's at least a sort of a backup i
mean
what if what if the earth is destroyed
by something
you know mars will be safe i mean i kind
of think of that as a little bit of a
of a slightly unconvincing argument
because
some of the things that are sort of bad
things that could happen i don't know
the
you know the ais take over the earth and
um uh and it's all
it's all bad news from there on um if
there's any
link it's a kind of a computer security
question how well
firewalled is the mars colony you know
if there's still
data being sent back and forth and you
know uh
software updates going to the mars
colony and things like this
it's certainly not obvious that the sort
of the ai that took over the earth isn't
going to wind up in the mars colony too
um and so there's sort of questions like
that
um i think one of the things is like
what what can one do in um on mars
that um one can't really do on earth and
one can look at things on the
on the earth there are examples for that
like how many people live in the
antarctic how many
people uh populate the south pole
uh uh station and
you know it's turned out there are
certain kinds of things one can do at
the south pole that
who knew that was a good idea for
example there's a neutrino detector
a particle physics experiment being done
at the south pole
and it's a good place for that um and
that's
uh was not i think self-evident when
people said
oh we're going to go explore and um and
find the south pole and so on
and what can we do there well there are
obviously things that can be done
with uh in sort of climate studies and
meteorology and so on
although i don't know how essential that
has been to be sort of uh
right at the south pole and so on and
it's obviously very inconvenient to live
at the south pole
and not that many people do it at any
given time
living on mars is going to be even more
inconvenient and the question is sort of
what's the um uh what's the payoff and i
mentioned earlier
when i was a kid people saying oh people
will be living under the oceans all the
time and of course that hasn't happened
at all because it's just difficult to do
and what's the point so to speak
now i mean there is a level of point in
something like
exploring mars it's like it's really
good to do these things which are
difficult for us because
every difficult thing like that that
gets done ends up having a lot of
consequences
for other kinds of other kinds of
technology for example the space program
landing
uh people on the moon in the in the late
1960s
was something that drove all kinds of
technology whether it's microprocessors
things to do with materials and so on
plus
it was also something that i think
encouraged a lot of people including
perhaps me
to get involved with kind of science and
things like this because
it was like look there are these
amazingly cool things that one can do
with science and
and technology and that has value in
itself
as kind of a look at these amazing
things we can do
um that's worth it's worth doing for
those reasons but but it's an
interesting challenge to think about for
example on the moon
um what kinds of things could one do you
know on the far side of the moon
it's shielded from sort of all the radio
emissions from the earth
we could build some terrific radio
telescopes and things
um maybe there are uh sort of that the
moon has no
uh doesn't have seismic activity it has
no earthquakes because it doesn't have a
liquid core
um and although i think there are some
some tiny
moonquakes that are of different origin
that have to do with
the fact that the um uh the moon is
being distorted by tidal forces by
gravity from the earth and that's
causing occasional
sort of glitches in it but uh you know
someone can start imagining well it's
you know could one build the giant
gravitational wave detector on the moon
uh which uh things like that um
and then there's the question of can we
mine the moon for something
that we don't have on the earth one of
the interesting things when the first
moon rocks were brought back
from the moon it was like well actually
these rocks are kind of pretty much the
same as the rocks on the earth
it wasn't known i mean it could have
been the case that the moon was
something which was kind of captured
from um uh wasn't originally formed
along with the earth it could have been
something that was separately captured
captured in fact the current theory for
the uh the current sort of leading
theory for the origin of the moon
the so-called big splat theory that's a
rather strange theory because it has
many steps
says well there was this little thing
that uh collided with the earth
and that caused the earth to kind of
melt and produce all this
ejected stuff and that ejected
stuff formed the moon but also this
piece that collided with the earth
is also part of the moon and if you look
at the structure of the moon
although it looks perfectly spherical to
us on the outside
the constitution of the rock inside it
is not uniform and it kind of has one
big blob on one side
which potentially is something to do
with that impact that originally formed
the moon
but it could have been the case that all
of the moon
was very foreign stuff that was very
unlike the earth i mean it could have
been full of gold or something
which people might have found useful or
not um turns out
it's not that way it's very similar
rocks to the to the earth
and so the the question of you know can
you mine the moon for something
of of great value is still an open
question
um uh and uh you know it certainly
the first time there are sort of
commercially available moon rocks
people will will get them just because
they're a cool thing to have
um whether it would turn out that
there's some very interesting kinds of
rocks
that exist on the moon that don't exist
on the earth um
i'm not sure i mean one thing about the
moon because it doesn't have an
atmosphere
on the earth lots of kind of rocks
tend to get kind of weathered down so
things that would otherwise be sort of
sharp breaks where there's a very very
sharp kind of razor-like
piece to a rock that doesn't tend to
exist on the earth because of
wind and rain and all those kinds of
things tend to break
to break down those kind of very sharp
pieces but on the moon there are sharp
pieces like that and so that
leads to somewhat different kinds of of
rock
at least superficially maybe the
internally the rock is the same kind of
thing as the earth
but um at the level of sort of the the
detailed shapes and so on it can be
different and and that maybe
provides some things where well i mean
in a sense it might be like
uh we are used to doing things like
cutting gemstones
with very specific angles to achieve
various effects
and maybe they're on the moon there are
sort of naturally cut
things that are of interest i'm not sure
well okay there's a question from derek
here
why do the planets orbit in the same
plane
so that's a it's a good question um
if in the center of the solar system the
sun
the planets are the earth orbits the sun
and it's in a particular plane so the
earth is sort of orbiting around it's a
it's a
almost perfectly circular orbit a little
bit elliptical um
orbiting the sun and that plane
defines what's called the plane of the
ecliptic
um it's called that because it's it's
related to the way that eclipses occur
but it's basically the plane defined by
the sun in the middle the orbit of the
earth
well turns out the planets basically
orbit
all orbit in pretty much the same plane
the pluto
which used to be considered a planet is
now considered a
a minor planet i guess um orbits
not quite in the same plane so it's it's
at an angle
to that plane so why do all the plants
orbit in a plane
it's because when they were formed they
were formed
as a kind of a sheet of material uh
around
the around when the sun was formed so
why does that happen
it's sort of the same reason that our
galaxy is flat a galaxy is a spiral
galaxy that's
that's kind of a flat thing it's
something where once things are spinning
around
there's a tendency for it to be the case
that they sort of
they they the the the sort of this whole
disc of accreting material is spinning
and it will tend to be the case that
gravity
will make it kind of squash into a kind
of a pancake it's spinning around that's
defining where
which direction will be the um the
direction that it sort of extended
outward in
and that's uh the um
uh and that's that that's the um uh
that so so all the material when a star
for is formed
all the material that's kind of being
pulled in that's making the star
will tend to be sort of squashed down
onto this one plane
it's kind of rotating around with the
star and as the planets were formed
from that kind of uh mass of material
that
um eventually gravity was making that
material
form into clumps and those clumps are
our planets and i think that the um
the question of uh so so in a sense
uh well around um
around the sun the planets are all
orbiting
around planets there are moons orbiting
and in fact the moons tend to be in more
or less the same plane
as the plane of the ecliptic as the
plane in which
the the the uh planets orbit around the
sun the earth's moon is actually at an
angle
of 20 something degrees 25 degrees maybe
the earth's moon is at a surprisingly
large angle
with respect to the plane of the
ecliptic and that's
thought to have something to do with
this big splat that i mentioned earlier
about the way the moon was formed but
most planetary moons
are more or less aligned like the moons
of jupiter the first
uh uh uh other moons to be discovered by
galileo in 1608
they they are in the in that same plane
and um so it's kind of a and you can ask
about well so another thing that is also
in the same plane
is um the rings of saturn the rings of
saturn are kind of like an
unformed into moons collection of pieces
of rock and so on
which for various detailed reasons about
the way the moons of saturn work
and so on they those things have not
been sort of accreted down
into uh single uh sort of
individual moons there's still lots of
little individual pieces of rock
circling around saturn and making this
nice ring pattern
and so one might ask well if that
happens for saturn does it also
happen in the solar system and the
answer is yes
the sun has rings around it and those
rings
are the the asteroid is the asteroid
belt basically
the collection of small lumps of
rock basically that are mostly between
the orbit of mars and jupiter and so
it's um it's in a sense it's like
the the planets are like the moons of
the sun
and the the asteroid belt is kind of
like the ring of of uh
uh the ring of the sun so to speak so
this question
about whether planets tend to orbit and
tend to be in this plane
uh yes the planets that we have are
mostly in this plane the ones that are
uh
more the things like pluto
that were well i'm not quite sure why
pluto is not in the same plane it's it's
it was um
i think hmm i'm not sure as you get out
to
outer uh bodies um in this ought cloud
and things like that i i think that the
the concentration into the plane
is no longer as strong as it is when
you're when you're dealing with things
that are
in the more inner solar system closer to
the sun
and uh clearly well one other question
is
if two planets collided with each other
for example or got very close to
colliding
they would be they would kind of uh
they would be that their orbits would be
would be very much changed
and those changed orbits might not stay
in the plane
of um of the solar system particularly
in fact one of the questions is
how many planets did our solar system
start with you know we think we we have
eight right now
but did we start with a lot more planets
or or what and i think the the current
estimates are that
maybe we started with twice as many
planets as we have today
and the planets the extra planets
were ejected because somehow when they
were orbiting around
they got too close to the orbit of
another planet and that led to
uh them to go at a very high speed that
would and at a slightly wrong angle so
that then they would escape the gravity
of the sun
and get sort of become wandering planets
wandering between stars
and so so maybe half of all planets that
were formed when stars were formed
have ended up becoming sort of wandering
planets
and i think in at this point we know
about
i guess hundreds of exoplanet systems
places where we can detect the presence
of planets around other stars
most of the time those are big planets
that we detect because those are the
easier ones to see
there are no doubt smaller planets as
well and i think that those
uh tend to also form in these planes for
the same reasons as
as our solar system did that that when
the planets were
formed the um uh it was
it was through this this sort of disc
that was associated with the formation
of the star
now an interesting question i realize i
don't know the answer to
is our solar system we have one
one star at the center we just have the
sun but there are many binary stars
in our galaxy even ternary stars where
there are two stars that are very nearby
that are orbiting each other
and they have planets orbiting around
the both of them
for example alpha centauri the nearest
star other than the sun that's a triple
star system
with uh with three stars executing some
somewhat complicated orbit
um with respect to each other and so
they're very interesting possibilities
i don't think there's an example of this
yet knowing
uh where where the where the planets
don't orbit around with us
with all the compass stars in the center
and then just orbiting around those but
instead sort of weave their way between
the stars so to speak
so that you'd end up with strange
situations where uh
and you know what you would imagine in
in the sky
of a planet with a binary star because
the planet is orbiting around the binary
star together
what you see in the sky is two suns that
are pretty close together
um but if you were in a situation where
you were kind of your planet was
threading its way between
these stars you would see a very
different and much more peculiar
kind of uh display so to speak
anyway um
there's a question from from king of
phobos and demos
the the the um uh the asteroids
um that orbit mars are they in the plane
of the ecliptic i believe the answer is
yes and the reason i think i know that
is that uh they are actually closer to
the plane than the moon is
because i believe that there is an
eclipse uh sort of
every every time those those moons
orbit mars so for example an eclipse is
is produced a solar eclipse is produced
when the moon
is between the sun and the earth and it
so happens at this point in the history
of the earth
the the size of the moon as seen in the
sky
its its size based on how far away it is
is basically equal to the size of the
sun
as seen from the earth so the sun is
obviously much much bigger than the moon
but it's also much further away than the
moon but sort of
it so happens that this time in the
history of the earth
the the moon and the sun sort of agree
in size when you see them in the sky the
moon is gradually getting further away
from the earth
and so gradually it will no longer cover
the disk of the sun
it will no longer be the same size it
will end up being smaller than the disk
of the sun
in the sky but right now it agrees
and so what eclipses happen solar
eclipses happen a total solar eclipse
happens
when the moon is just right in front of
the sun as seen from the earth
and so you might say well if the moon
orbited
in the same plane as the earth is
orbiting the sun
then every time the moon orbits around
every lunar month every 28 days or so
that the moon orbits around the earth
every time it does that every time it's
in the position
between the the earth and the sun
you would have an eclipse because gosh
it would be in the way
it isn't that way because there's this
angle that the that um the
moon the orbit of the moon is not
aligned with the plane of the ecliptic
and that's why
it doesn't end up uh being between the
earth and the sun
every every lunar month but my
recollection is that for the satellites
of mars
which are much smaller in the sky
relative to
uh the the um they are small compared to
the disk of the sun i think
when seen from mars um but nevertheless
they do cross
the disk of the sun i think that's been
seen by um
uh by some uh rovers and things on
landers on mars
i think there are pictures of that um uh
of that
those kinds of eclipses um
let's see there's a question here uh
there's a couple of questions here what
makes a planet a planet
oh well i mean it isn't a star what
makes a star a star
what makes the star a star is that it
has it's producing energy
through nuclear fusion reactions it's um
well i say that's what makes the star a
star if i think about a neutron star
which is kind of the end state of a star
somewhat more massive than the sun it's
like a giant atomic nucleus
10 kilometers across um that's no longer
producing energy through nuclear
reactions but one would still call it a
star
so that that's sort of an exception to
what i'm saying but generally
your typical star is producing energy
through nuclear reactions a planet does
not do that
a planet doesn't a planet is tends to be
something that is in a sense uh there
are no
there no situations in which lots of
atomic nuclei are being squashed
together
and fusing and producing energy if that
ever happened
if jupiter was quite a bit bigger than
it actually is
then the force of gravity would cause
sort of the internal parts of jupiter
to get squashed together to the point
where the nuclei would
would be pushed together and nuclei
would fuse they would produce energy and
it would turn into a star
so what you have that
is anything that is
big enough i what is it maybe a tenth
the size of the sun maybe a little bit
smaller than that
i'm not sure what the lower limit is and
i'm not sure it's completely known
at what point a lump of stuff
in out there will have enough gravity
enough self-gravity that it will kind of
contract
and squash its contents to the point
where
they will undergo nuclear fusion and it
will become a star
the sun is a comparatively large star
and the their
their stars much larger like beetlejuice
for example is a much much larger star
which has a
which is kind of like the sun but
extended out to the orbit of jupiter or
something
um but uh if you look at the the
distribution of all
stars the sun is a comparatively large
star
most stars are considerably smaller than
the sun
but there's a lower limit to the size of
stars because below that lower limit
the force of gravity no longer is
sufficient
to make the thing sort of concentrate
down to produce nuclear fusion to
produce energy to make it be
a star that's shining and producing
light and so on and so
things below that limit well they're
considered to be planets
now if you say uh well does it
if it's a a random planet that escaped
to solar system
is it still a planet i don't think we've
had to address that question of
terminology yet
we've seen so far one interstellar
asteroid
asteroid
this thing um um i don't know how to
pronounce it well
that came through our solar system a
couple of years ago now
um and we knew it didn't come from our
solar system because it was going way
too fast
it would have been it wasn't something
that would have
uh would be in orbit around the sun it
was going too fast to be an orbit around
the sun
and it was clearly something that had
come from another solar system
or come from somewhere else in the
galaxy we don't know exactly where
and so it's pretty likely that there are
such objects
coming through our solar system a few
times a year at least
um and uh but we haven't we haven't yet
seen anything the size of a planet
come through and uh obviously that would
be an interesting thing to see
and um the uh uh and
it will be kind of quite interesting to
see
uh whether the uh whether the material
and
the rock and so on and that how similar
that is to what we find in in our solar
system and so on
i mean we're the thing to understand is
that
in the evolution of our galaxy there are
different populations of stars
and so in the very first stars
they pretty much get to use the sort of
raw material that comes from the very
beginnings of the universe
which is mostly hydrogen and about a
quarter helium
and so on the very the elements with
very small numbers of protons and
the elements at the beginning of the
periodic table they are the elements
that mostly
uh were produced in the big bang at the
beginning of the universe
um something like gold wasn't produced
in any significant any uh anything more
than infinitesimally
in the uh in the very early universe
and that got produced by stars being
formed
the stars eventually have supernovas
where they explode
and in the process of doing that things
of these heavy elements get produced
now by the time the earth came along to
be formed 4.6 billion years ago
there had already been generations of
stars
that had existed been formed
blown up produced heavy elements like
gold
and that's where all the gold on on the
earth and so on comes from
is it's all been processed through these
uh these supernovas
um and uh uh from from earlier
generations of stars
so this question of of um uh
the so basically any kind of thing
that's pulled together by gravity
it's going to form a planet-like thing
now it depends on what kinds of elements
are in there
whether it's mostly hydrogen and things
like that um
whether the planet is big enough
that it can keep hydrogen gas so
on the earth for example our atmosphere
is mostly nitrogen and oxygen
and that is the reason
so if there had been hydrogen gas in the
earth
that hydrogen gas would have escaped
into space and the reason is
that at that there's a certain
speed that these molecules are going at
if that speed is more than the escape
velocity of the earth
25 000 miles an hour the velocity you
need to kind of escape the gravity of
the earth
if the speed of the molecules is more
than that they can escape
from the from the earth's gravity if the
speed of the molecules is less than that
then they're trapped by the gravity of
the earth and they're kept
like in the atmosphere of the earth and
so it turns out that at the temperatures
that exist on the earth that uh nitrogen
and oxygen
are sort of big enough atoms that the
the energy that's provided by the
temperature is such
that they the the the speeds of the
molecules
aren't large enough for them to escape
the gravity of the earth
but for hydrogen it is large enough to
escape the gravity of the earth and
that's why
there basically isn't any hydrogen in
the atmosphere of the earth
now jupiter on the other hand has a much
larger escape velocity
and so it is uh um the
even even the hydrogen gas that exists
there isn't the the the molecules aren't
going fast enough to escape the gravity
of jupiter
and so a lot of the atmosphere of
jupiter is is hydrogen
now when you get sort of uh the when you
get into the inner
layers of jupiter it's mostly mostly gas
but when you get
far further and further into the planet
um
you end up there there are higher and
higher pressures that's the same reason
the same reason that if you go under the
ocean for example you go down
into the ocean you'll get very quickly
to higher and higher pressures of water
because there's just a lot of water on
top of you that's kind of
uh weighing down on you to produce that
pressure and so that works on on jupiter
too
the center of jupiter is probably a
bunch of hydrogen that's been squashed
really really hard
it's been squashed so hard that it turns
into a solid and actually hydrogen is a
metal probably
when it's solid so it's a sort of
metallic core made of hydrogen
that exists probably in the center of
jupiter as a result of the sort of
pressure
of all that atmosphere on top um just
like under the ocean on the earth
pushing all pushing that core together
um
so question um
let's see it's a question from memes why
do most planets stars and galaxies seem
to spin the same way
i don't believe they do um the i mean
what does it mean to spin the same way i
mean
you're it depends on where you know if
you have um
uh unless i'm very confused i think i
think there are
there are uh attempts
to count left and right
how does this work i'm now confused
because you think about
which way is this spinning you know you
have your thumb sticking out and your
hand is going around one way
and that's spinning one way but if you
uh no no the point is you don't know
which way is up
there's no sort of thumb sticking out of
the the galaxy it's just something
that's
that's rotating around and you don't you
don't know which way is up if you knew
which way is up you would know whether
it was
going clockwise or going
counterclockwise but you don't i think
um i think that there's a uh
yeah they're
so
let's see there are questions here
oh gosh there's a question from virgil
what did nasa do to avoid astronauts
getting huge amounts of cosmic rays
so in the sun for example produces light
but it also produces a stream of other
kinds of particles like protons
and electrons but particularly protons
and they stream out from the sun
they're produced by processes going on
in the sun
and they're like radiation it's like the
kind of thing one wants to avoid
you know but wants to avoid getting too
many x-rays one wants to avoid
uh the radiation
um is just particles like protons or
electrons or whatever
that are going fast and they're just
individual particles
that's kind of so-called ionizing
radiation it's called ionizing radiation
because
it turns ordinary atoms into ions an ion
is an atom
which has had electrons pulled out of it
and so ionizing radiation
is you send a high energy proton or high
energy electron
through a lump of material and it the
electrical effect of the proton for
example
going at that speed will will kind of
tear
electrons out of atoms and will ionize
those atoms
and for example if that happens to the
atoms
in biological material you can get all
kinds of
uh destruction of pieces of dna or
whatever else
associated with just this charged
particle kind of barreling through
so it's it's sort of a bad thing the
typical energy
the um the energy of cosmic rays from
the sun
uh cosmic rays is kind of the name for
this um
uh well it's it's it's kind of the
generic name although there's also the
notion of space weather
where you're looking at just the flux of
the particles the the flow of particles
from the sun
but i guess that one talks about them as
as cosmic rays and particularly there
are cosmic rays
the the peak of the energy is around
1 billion electron volts which is oh
gosh
how to think about that energy um
that's an energy comparable to the rest
energy of a proton
so it means that a proton is going at a
large fraction of the speed of light a
proton with that energy
is going at a very large fraction of the
speed of light now
most of those particles that come from
the sun
the ones that are low energy
particularly the electrons
will uh be caught by the magnetic field
of the earth
and will kind of spiral into the
magnetic poles of the earth
and that's why there's there's somewhat
higher cosmic ray
radiation um at the poles it's also what
produces things like the aurora
when when those high energy electrons
kind of uh
interact with things like oxygen in the
upper atmosphere
those high energy electrons ex
make the oxygen um kind of they they
pull the electrons
into a state where when they when they
um
decay down again they they end up
emitting light
and that's what that's what produces the
aurora but um in general
the um uh
there are um these these cosmic rays
are a sort of being being streamed out
from the sun
now the magnetic field of the earth
causes let's see how does this work
these things called the van allen belts
which were discovered when when early
artificial satellites were flown
which are associated with magnetic field
of the earth
and they are a place where i guess
the particles from the sun tend to get
concentrated
and prevented from uh from hitting the
earth
and um how does that work exactly hmm
i'm not completely sure how that works
there is a
um i mean the magnetic field of the
earth is kind of um
it's this thing called the magnetosphere
and
i am uh
kind of forms this magnetic sheath
around the earth but i'm now a little
bit confused by how that actually works
um with respect to cosmic rays but
basically
the there are um in space
also i should say when a cosmic ray hits
the earth's atmosphere
um it mostly just
the let's say a proton most of the
so-called primary cosmic radiation is
protons
um it hits the top of the atmosphere and
pretty soon it hits an atom in the
atmosphere
and they both kind of go they both
produce a bunch of other particles and
those particles are quickly absorbed
and nothing reaches the surface of the
earth most of what reaches the surface
are muons which come from reactions of
protons
hit other protons they produce things
called pions the pions decay into muons
the muons actually decay if they were at
rest they would decay
in about two microseconds um but
they they survive long enough that they
get to the surface of the earth at sea
level
and um actually i have on my computer
now a little a cute little device
that will actually see the tracks of
muons going through my computer
um and uh they're about to maybe one a
minute or something
go through a typical something about the
size of a person
on the surface of the earth at sea level
if you go up to a
um you know if you go a mile high or
something to denver or you go
up to some mountain that's um that's
twice that height or something like this
um you'll get considerably more cosmic
radiation you get considerably more
cosmic rays including some of the
primary protons
that didn't yet interact when they when
they come through the atmosphere um
so in in space you get even more cosmic
rays
and um the uh
and so it is the case that uh
there are significant numbers of cosmic
rays and you know astronauts one of the
one of the interesting phenomena is that
if one of those high energy particles
goes through your eye
it produces what's called tyrannical
radiation it's a
uh if it produces light basically
and even if you have your eyes closed if
one of those particles goes through the
the interior of your eye it will produce
a bunch of light
which the retina of your eye will say oh
there's light
it's you know one just saw something
even though one's eyes were closed that
sort of internal
um that's an internal source of light
and that's certainly something
astronauts report
seeing i think that as you get
away from the earth um even going to the
moon
or going to mars you're exposed to a lot
more of this
of these cosmic rays and when there's a
big
uh solar flare or something like that
you can be exposed to even more
radiation from the sun of this type and
sort of it's a
it's a challenge and an issue how you
shield
astronauts who are going to mars for
example and people talk about putting
big tanks of water around
the exterior of spacecraft going to mars
to shield for that
it's also not completely clear i think
what the effect of that kind of
radiation it's like having many many
many
uh x-rays many uh you know cat
ct scans or whatever done those are
those
x-rays which are another kind of
ionizing radiation
um it's like having many many x-rays
done on your way to mars
and does that have an effect you get
tumors things like that
um it's not um uh it's not um
not not completely clear what the result
of that is
um so
let's see uh there's a question here
from king how exactly do you detect
muons um uh okay so
there are a variety of ways to do it
essentially what you're detecting
is that a process of ionization
when there's a charged particle a muon
is a charged particle
um like an electron has the same charge
as the electron a muon is kind of like
an electron except it's about 206 times
heavier
than the electron but a muon is coming
through
and it is ionizing it is producing this
it is turning neutral atoms that have an
equal number of protons and electrons
into atoms where some of the electrons
have been torn out
um and so you can detect that because
there are electrical effects of that
ionization process
and typically what you have to do there
are several different methods
very early method was things like geiger
counters or geiger tubes
and the way those work is okay here's
basically the idea
you imagine that you're going to
make you're going to make a piece of
electric discharge so for example when a
lightning strike happens
that's happening because the electric
potential of the clouds
is much higher than the electric
potential of the ground and
what's happening is the it's essentially
the the um
uh the voltage is the difference of it's
like you have a very high voltage
thing and you you have your you know a
million volts
uh between this thing here and the thing
on the ground
and the question is when you have a high
enough voltage
it will be the case that materials break
down
they that with a high enough voltage
voltage is kind of
how hard you're pushing electrons to go
through a material
when you have a high enough voltage
eventually you'll be able to push
electrons through basically any material
and so you get this phenomena of
discharge so you see that if you have
you know when you have a spark for
example through air
it's usually pretty hard to push
electricity through air to push the
electrons through air to make an
electric current
but if you push hard enough the air will
break down
and you'll get this trail where you have
a sort of a spark
where where the electrons will be moving
through the air so
every material has a certain breakdown
voltage
at which the um uh it's actually voltage
it's voltage per per distance um
the um a certain maximum actually the
electric field which is voltage per
distance
um a maximum value of that before it
will just break down
and say forget it i'm going to let the
electrons just go through
um well so in a geiger counter
what's done is to make it so that you
have something where you have a
high voltage where you get a gas
so it's right at the point where it
would have this electric discharge but
it isn't yet having that electric
discharge
and when the gas gets ionized gets this
ionizing particle go through
then the electric discharge will happen
in that place and so
you'll often uh they've usually seen in
kind of old movies at this point this
kind of click click click click click
sound from a geiger counter and when it
detects radiation the clicks get
faster faster much faster each of those
clicks
is a little a sense lightning strike
inside the
inside the geiger tube because it's a
place where
there is electrical breakdown of the gas
where the gas was was held at this very
high voltage and just in places where
the particle went through
you you detect um you detect that
particle and it makes this kind of
clicking sound
okay so that was that's sort of one form
of particle detection
there are several forms of particle
detection there are much fancier
versions of that
where you have a whole array of wires
and they're all maintained at
a high voltage and so you can then
detect
where the track of the particle goes
because you can see which wires
had uh which would which when the
electric discharge occurs
where did the electricity go with
respect to these wires
and um that's that's one kind of method
and sometimes you can do
timing information where you say oh i've
got this
long wire and i can tell that this kind
of lightning strike little miniature
lightning strike
happened at this particular moment
relative to the voltage that i put
down this wire and so on and i can
measure the time delay and that tells me
where on the wire the particle was
detected
there are a variety of other methods of
particle detection two major other ones
are things called scintillation counters
and semiconductor detectors so
scintillation counters
are basically a kind of plastic where
when the particles go through they
produce
the the interaction of the particles uh
with the material in the plastic
excites the atoms to the point where
they emit light
it's it's very similar to what happens
in the aurora where
the charged particles that are spiraling
in from cosmic rays
um interact with things like oxygen and
nitrogen in the upper atmosphere
they make those atoms go into this kind
of excited state
and as the atoms decay they emit light
and it's the same kind of thing in a
scintillator in a scintillation counter
you have these these big kind of usually
plastic paddle like things at least
they used to be that shape i'm not sure
there was that shape anymore but there
would be a
sort of flat blade and um you would
and then there would be a kind of what
would happen is there'd be a flash of
light
somewhere in this plastic where the
particle went through and you would kind
of
use it like a like a um like a piece of
fiber optics
you would concentrate you would kind of
uh everywhere in this
in this lump of plastic you could detect
light
that was generated anywhere in the lump
of plastic in sort of the base of the
paddle
and um uh you could then uh measure
that amount of light with essentially a
camera it used to be a so-called photo
multiplier tube
which is a very sensitive kind of uh
camera-like
thing okay so that's the second method
the one that's become popular in more
recent times
and the one that the little usb device
that i have on my computer is based on
is semiconductor particle detection
i mean i have to say many years ago well
okay so
when you have something like a memory
chip a memory chip
is a piece of semiconductor and it has
all these little wires on it and all
these little transistors on it
and when an ionizing particle goes
through it
basically dumps electricity into the
into the memory chip so it's that that
ionization
is sort of a a let's add some more
electrons in this place
well the memory of a computer is based
on having
electrons present or not present at
particular places
defined by these transistors and these
wires that cross over
and so on so when an ionizing particle
goes through it's like dumping a whole
bunch of extra
electrons there and it is uh what you
thought was a zero for example in your
memory it's like well no
it just got changed to be a one um and
so
the way semiconductor particle detectors
work is they're kind of like memory
chips
except that they're what one's doing is
ones looking for
the errors that occur in the memory chip
one's looking at the places where
a cosmic ray went through that caused
the memory
chip the the the bit that was stored in
memory to change
and because the memory is kind of laid
out in an array
and you can kind of tell well it was the
bit at this particular memory location
that changed
it tells you where on the memory chip
the particle went through
and i have to say i remember back in the
late 1970s i was
talking to my friends in particle
physics experimental particle physics
and saying you know it has to be the
case that these semiconductor devices
um that we know that that there are
problems that happen from cosmic rays
from in semiconductor devices surely you
could use that as a particle detector
and they were saying no no no it
couldn't possibly work but anyway a few
decades go by
and that's a very common way of
detecting particles now it has to be
said that
one of the issues is with cosmic rays
and and memory chips
and cpus in general microprocessors in
general
is yes when ionizing particles go
through
they dump electricity into these things
and they mess up the operation of the
you know they mess up the data and the
memory chips they mess up the operation
of cpus and so on
and so that means when you put
electronics into satellites for example
which are exposed to cosmic rays or you
send them to
to mars or whatever else you have to be
very careful about
um arranging for about those
those microprocessor chips to make sure
that they're not that their operation is
not just scrambled by cosmic rays
and so one way to do that is to have um
the um uh is is to have shielding around
so
so it turns out that at least for
charged particles
uh actually it's true in general the the
um
the heavier the element heavier in the
sense that it has more
higher atomic number um more um
uh well more protons and neutrons in its
nucleus
uh but well for charged particles most
important with protons
um the uh the the heavier the element it
is
the better it will shield ionizing
radiation and so lead
is usually the best shielding and that's
what you'll see you know when if you get
a dental x-ray or something
and somebody gives you this lead apron
um it's
it's lead because the uh uh the the
x-rays are are stopped much more
efficiently by lead
than they are by lighter elements led
being the
the um the the sort of heaviest
easy to acquire element um and in fact
the uh
at a mathy level the um uh the the
amount of stopping
goes up like the square of the atomic
number
of of of the elements um
and uh so in any case the um so when you
when you put electronics on satellites
you can shield it you can also
use electronics that's been hardened uh
it always used to be the case i don't
know if it's still true that you could
buy
the mil spec the military specification
version
of uh pretty much any kind of
microprocessor
and that would be hardened against
certain kinds of electromagnetic pulses
and things
and it will be the better thing to use
if you're putting it in space
but any case the um uh so
the way that you detect these particles
is also the thing
that causes trouble for electronics and
you can by by looking for example a
semiconductor detector exactly where did
the particle go
where which particular memory locations
got
scrambled you can see what the track of
the particle is
i was going to mention that it always
used to be the case that when computers
were installed
in high altitude places uh famously like
the los
alamos national lab in los alamos new
mexico which is about seven thousand
feet
um it would be the case that there would
be more cosmic rays there
and so there would be more errors in uh
computer memories and so on
that would exist there this became sort
of a non-issue
because most serious server computers
have uh error correction which means
they have extra bits of memory that are
included which are used to check the
rest of the memory
so that you can check oh because most
cosmic rays just lead to a single bit
error
so you can usually correct that with the
error correcting memory
other kinds of electronics like mobile
phones for example
typically don't have error correcting
memory or haven't in the past had error
correcting memory
and it's sort of an interesting question
why one doesn't see more effects
from sort of oh a cosmic ray went
through my phone
and actually there'd been various um uh
possibilities
of um using phones as a big
detector of cosmic rays actually there's
a different way to do that
which is if you black out your phone
camera
then the device the charge coupled
device
that is the thing that detects light in
your camera
if a charged particle goes through it it
will generate what appears to be
a little flash of light and so there's
been various projects that say
let's take a whole bunch of cell phones
let's cover their cameras
and let's measure the light that comes
even from the covered camera so to speak
and use that to detect cosmic rays the
the
typical cosmic ray from the sun has an
energy i was mentioning of one gev in
the units of these things
one billion electron volts um that's
well that unit means
if you have a uh a one volt
of uh of potential difference
then one electron volt is the energy
that would be given to what an electron
that has sort of fallen through that
voltage
so to speak it's the it's the push given
to a single electron
by one volt is one electron volt so so
anyway that's a way of measuring energy
um the the highest energy cosmic rays
that have been observed
are around uh 10 to 21 or 10 to the 22
electron volts
so they are so energetic they are
like uh one joule of energy there
they're enough that uh that they're
firms like throwing an object
a big object and just throwing at a
reasonable speed
um that that's the same amount of energy
as is packed into a single proton
uh for the very highest energy cosmic
rays it's um
they're very few very high-energy cosmic
rays one of the things that happens is
just as there are particles that are
trapped in the magnetic field of the
earth
there are also particles that are
trapped in the magnetic field of the
galaxy
and there is a um uh
i think it's 10 to the 15 electron volts
is the maximum
energy of cosmic rays that are trapped
of of particles trapped in the magnetic
field of the galaxy
and then there's a very bizarre thing
that happens around 10 to the 19
electron volts i think
um a very strange phenomenon so if you
have a proton that has that high in
energy
it turns out you might think oh the
proton is just going through
interstellar space
into galactic space there's nothing for
it to hit
but actually there is because there's
the relic radiation from the big bang
the cosmic microwave background
and that consists of a large number of
low energy photons low energy particles
of light
that are just spread out throughout the
universe we detect them on earth
as uh radio radiation as
a a tiny radio signal so to speak
but they're just photons that are sort
of scattered throughout the universe
and when you have a sufficiently high
energy proton
it can it can actually hit one of those
photons
that is in the cosmic microwave
background and
it'll it'll scatter from that from that
thing
and it will it will typically lose
energy as a result of that
that scattering process so you have this
incredibly low energy
uh photon from the cosmic microwave
background this incredibly high energy
proton
and uh if if uh the the
the relativity tells one things about
how the how that scattering process
works
what matters is the uh
is the energy of the proton multiplied
by the energy
of the photon the square root of that
and that can be big enough that it is a
it's a substantial that there's a
substantial chance of that react
of that process happening and that it
scatters the proton out of the way
and causes it to lose energy um and so
that was a reason why people thought
there might never be cosmic rays above
about 10 to the 19 electron volts
and in fact cosmic rays maybe
20 or 30 years ago cosmic rays above
that limit were observed
and that kind of tells you something
about how far the cosmic rays have been
coming
because they if they've been tooling
along halfway across the universe
the chances are they will have hit a
piece of cosmic microwave background
before they get to us so it kind of
tells one
that even these high-energy cosmic rays
are coming from inside our galaxy
so then the challenge is on where do
these very high energy cosmic rays come
from
do they come from some of these um uh
quasar blazar
type things where there's these are
these astrophysical jets
that are very high energy jets of
particles
well and light um that
are probably associated with um mata
being pulled into black holes and
all kinds of exotic things like this um
so uh gosh
the um i think um
uh there's a question here from rj why
is water a good radiation shield
if it has low atomic numbers it's not
okay so this is a little bit complicated
the um uh
in with ionizing radiation
like a proton the main thing that's
causing a proton to get stopped by
material
is scattering from the nucleus through
electromagnetic processes a so-called
rutherford scattering it was discovered
by ernest rutherford
who is the person who discovered the
atomic nucleus in fact by noticing the
scattering process
that you shoot a a a proton
at a nucleus the proton the the nucleus
the proton is positively charged the
nucleus is positively charged
that means at least if it gets that that
there will be a force a repulsive
electrical force between the proton
because like charges repel
the proton and the nucleus will repel
each other but that force of repulsion
isn't particularly strong
unless the proton gets really really
close to the nucleus
and then there's this inverse square law
and that inverse square law
when the when the distance is very small
the the force will be very large
and that causes the proton to scatter
and that's sort of
one of the one of the effects okay so
that's for a proton
what about a high energy photon like a
gamma ray or an x-ray
how does that get stopped by matter well
what happens is
oh boy there's all kinds of physics here
what happens is
the the photon is coming through the
material
and the photon will produce will turn
into an electron positron pair
if the photon has an energy that is
larger than the rest energy of a proton
of an electron
plus a positron then when that photon is
kind of
kicked by the electric field of an
atomic nucleus
it will do what's called pair production
it will produce an electron positron
pair
and that electron positron pair are then
charged particles
and then they scatter from atomic nuclei
in the same kind of way that protons
would scatter from atomic nuclei
so that's that's the way that um so when
uh
um when a uh a piece of um when a
high-energy photon
comes into a material there's this sort
of conversion process that happens
where it is converted into electron
positron pairs
the electrons and positrons they
actually produce additional photons
which again that could get converted you
have this whole cascade this whole
shower
of material that gets a whole shower of
particles that are produced
and um so the uh
that's and what ends up happening to
these electrons in the end
they get captured by an atom and they
kind of spiral into the atom
and eventually um get get get captured
there
so that's that's uh so for photons
you need conversion of the photons into
charged particles and then there's this
cascade process
and i'm thinking that cascade process
uh let's see is that directly dependent
on atomic number
i think it is i think it also is just
like for protons
okay the next case is neutrons neutrons
are neutral particles
they do not there's no electrical
process that will deflect a neutron
to deflect a neutron you have to it
actually has to hit
an atomic nucleus and the strong nuclear
force
which is the force between protons and
neutrons and
and so on has to take effect and that's
how
you kind of um stop a a neutron
and um the uh the issue is
that um actually there's another effect
is that an important effect the neutron
has a magnetic dipole moment
it's like a little bar magnet um and it
does
have it is not a charged particle but it
is a particle that has a magnetic
uh uh effect and i
is that important oh gosh i've forgotten
but in any case the the the fact is that
no it isn't important that's that's not
important that's that's not the main
effect
so neutrons the main place where lots of
neutrons get produced is in nuclear
reactors
and so there's sort of a big issue of
how do you
stop the neutrons in a nuclear reactor
because the neutrons are what go from
one uh nuclear process to another that's
what leads to chain reactions
in nuclear reactors is mostly neutrons
that are being uh that are produced from
one one
atomic uh one one nuclear fission for
example
and they go and hit other nuclei and
they cause those nuclei to fall apart
and that produces more neutrons and
those cause more nuclei to fall apart
pretty soon you have this chain reaction
so in a
um in a nuclear reactor to control that
chain reaction you want to absorb those
neutrons
and there's a lot of detailed
information on different kinds of
materials that are so-called moderators
that um absorb neutrons and that was a
this big thing people have spent a lot
of effort
measuring neutron cross sections neutron
probabilities of interaction for
different materials
and so for example heavy water deuterium
oxide which has a
uh the where the hydrogens in the water
don't have just a single proton but a
proton and a neutron
that has very different characteristics
in terms of absorbing neutrons
from ordinary water and so that's some
that they're so-called water moderated
reactors and i think they're heavy water
moderated reactors
and these are things to do with neutron
absorption which works differently from
the from charged particles which have
this dependence on the atomic number
well we should we should wrap up soon
here but
um let's just see if there are any other
related questions here
um
uh why does an iron core result in a
supernova
um actually in a supernova so you have a
big star
a bit bigger than the sun the the star
is usually what's happening is uh
protons
are crashing together a very high speed
and a fusing to produce
uh two protons crashing together uh
they're like hydrogen nuclei
and they're fusing together to produce
helium nuclei which have two protons in
them
and that process of the the protons
it takes a lot of energy to to make them
crash together because you have to
overcome the fact that they're
electrically repelling each other
and so sufficiently high temperatures
you
you can push those those protons
together when they get close enough
they'll fuse and they'll release energy
and that's the primary energy that's
produced by the sun
is from proton burning so to speak or
hydrogen burning
from hydrogen hydrogens fusing and
producing helium
but then some helium also fuses together
and it produces
heavier elements and so on okay so what
happens is
eventually a star will have pretty much
used up all its hydrogen all its
hydrogen will have been converted to
helium
maybe the helium will have been
converted to lithium and it'll keep
going so to speak
and as as the star kind of uses up its
nuclear fuel
it is less able to keep itself it's less
able
to produce energy to kind of keep the
pressure of the star
keep the star kind of kind of pushed out
and not
crushed by gravity and what happens is
when it uses up
a bunch of its kind of nuclear fuel when
it uses up a bunch of the lighter
elements
because they've all fused into heavier
elements then it can no longer
uh it no longer has enough pressure to
withstand collapse from gravity
and this happens rather suddenly and um
it happens i think around the time of
oxygen burning silicon burning
i think these are the those reactions
start happening rather
rather rapidly and when those start to
happen
the sort of the the pressure produced in
the star
rapidly decreases and the star will just
collapse
the the um uh the outer regions of the
star
will just be pulled by gravity very
rapidly in and the whole thing will
crush
down into something much smaller when
that happens
there's a huge amount of energy
associated with that crushing down
process
and that then causes more nuclear
reactions to start up
that weren't able to start up before
because the star didn't have enough
temperature
to um to have enough enough energy for
the individual
individual uh nuclei to produce some
um that um uh
yeah no actually actually i'm saying
something slightly wrong here so
so the star starts collapsing and what
happens is things like silicon burning
and oxygen burning it's not burning in
the usual sense
it's nuclear fusion those things
start to happen it takes more energy
takes
more energy if you have two silicon
nuclei
they're pretty big they have pretty big
electric charge you need to push them
together much harder
you need to push hydrogen nuclei
together to overcome the force of
repulsion from the electric
electric charges and so it takes a
higher energy a higher temperature
to make that happen but that temperature
is achieved when the star is collapsing
and that moment of collapse it suddenly
will achieve those higher energies
higher temperatures
and that will cause new nuclear
reactions to start up
and that that happens very suddenly in
matters of seconds or less
those new nuclear reactions will start
up and then kaboom
the whole star explodes um because
uh because there's been this huge amount
of energy released
that uh newly released that will just
throw everything
uh all over the place and um the
there's usually that's the point at
which
heavy elements get produced because the
way that nuclear
reactions work anything beyond iron
it's not possible when you when you're
when you're getting energy by
by pushing nuclei together um you
you don't gain energy by pushing nuclei
together when you go anywhere beyond
iron
beyond iron it starts to go the other
way and when you get to things like
uranium and plutonium
when you split those nuclei apart you
get energy
but the minimum energy point is iron 56
and that's the place where kind of
everything
uh you you don't you you get energy by
pushing things together to get to iron
but um uh that that's that's as far as
you can get with that
but at the point where a supernova is
happening you're pushing things together
so hard that doesn't matter that it
doesn't
that you're just pushing these nuclei
together incredibly hard and that's how
you form
that's one of the processes by which you
form heavy elements it's so-called rapid
process r process nuclear synthesis
and that happens in the moments of a
supernova and that's where some fraction
of the
so the gold in the world comes from and
other heavy elements
um the other process is a slower process
which
is the result i think of um
a high energy of nuclei that are
produced by the supernova and that are
sort of streaming outwards
at a at a high energy and they're
gradually interacting
with other nuclei that were in the
exterior of the supernova
and that's a more gradual process that
again is a process that creates
uh heavier elements
well okay maybe one last question here
which is
from from cap how do nuclear blasts
affect computers we already talked about
a little bit of of um
of this uh in effect earlier
the main thing when
you have a nuclear blast
you get uh lots of radiation produced
lots of charged particles produced
by the nuclear reactions you also get
a lot of energy release that produces a
shock front
that's just a like a a um just
just literally physically moving the air
and so on fast but there's another thing
that's produced
it's called the electromagnetic pulse
and
that is produced by uh rapid ionization
i think of the air near the nuclear
explosion
it's i think that's that's the source of
it so in other words it's it's
the nuclear explosion happens it's
releasing a lot of energy it's
producing lots of ionization it produces
a it makes the um uh the atmosphere for
example but actually this happens in
space as well so
it's the main point is that there's a
lot of
uh of of charged particles
that are generated in the nuclear
explosion and those charged particles
are made to go fast and they're
accelerated a lot
and whenever a charged particle is
accelerated it emits
uh electromagnetic radiation that's just
a feature of the way that
electromagnetism works is that when you
when you accelerate a charged particle
it produces electromagnetic radiation
that's how radio antennas work
and in this case you have all these
particles that are very high energy
and they produce a whole bunch of
electromagnetic radiation
in particular they produce this pulse of
electromagnetic radiation
that is across a whole range of
in the it's a radio down into microwaves
etc etc etc
um even to visible light and so on but
that
pulse that electromagnetic pulse is
something which has a really bad effect
on computers
because it's like it's like putting this
um it's like having kind of a um
uh it's kind of almost like having a
lightning strike go through the computer
not quite but
but it's sort of the same idea of this
very intense
pulse of electricity going through the
computer or
or and so what tends to happen is low
voltage electronics like
microprocessors and so on can get
completely destroyed by electromagnetic
pulses
and so that was a during the cold war
that was sort of a big deal that that
uh particularly american electronics was
being made with sort of low voltage
microprocessors
semiconductors all that kind of thing
soviet electronics
people were saying it's really very
primitive it's using vacuum tubes
this and they're much higher voltage
electronics
but one feature of that kind of lower
technology electronics
was that it was much less subject to
being destroyed by electromagnetic
pulses
i think there are better ways to harden
microprocessors that are now known but
basically it's sort of bad news
for um for microprocessors
when they're subjected to
electromagnetic pulse from a nuclear
explosion and
that's one of the reasons why if for
example there was a nuclear explosion in
space
it would destroy the electronics of lots
of satellites the
the satellites that weren't in the
shadow of the earth would tend to get
destroyed by that pulse
and that's one of one of the many
reasons why let's hope nobody ever
detonates a nuclear explosion in space
um but in any case uh with that perhaps
not um
um uh
um not
not so positive thought um i think we
have to wrap up for today
lots of interesting questions here i
look forward to um
uh being able to address more of these
next time
well thanks for joining us and